apparently Matthew McConaughey and Jared
Leto were like hey why don't we just be
in a movie where we're really freaking
skinny both of us they're like okay
let's do it all right all right all
right Dallas buyers club is a movie that
I have been wanting to see for a while
I've heard a lot of great buzz about it
namely the acting Matthew McConaughey's
in this film Jared Leto's in the film
it's a true story about a man who
contracts AIDS and he decides to use
this horrible situation as a way to
benefit others he figures out a way to
kind of ride the line of the law and get
certain vitamins and minerals and things
like that that aren't quite approved by
the FDA into the hands of people who
can't afford them or into the hands of
people that the hospitals are not giving
them these things and the only way they
can do that is to create this Dallas
buyers club this thing where they don't
actually pay him for these unapproved
drugs they pay for a membership to him
and then he gives them the drugs for
free so movies basically about this
guy's plight his fight for his own
health and others and a fight against
the system kind of of the hospital
system in the FDA it's also a story
about how he becomes friends with people
that he normally wouldn't have thought
of as friends in the past this is a
really good movie and it's the kind of
movie that is extremely hard to watch
and rarely do I encounter films like
that usually a film that's hard for me
to wash is just one that's unnecessarily
grotesque this movie is so realistically
dirty where you could you're just like
of course he got AIDS like they're
showing the things that he did before he
contracted AIDS and you're like yeah I
can completely understand why this guy
got AIDS because he just led the worst
most filthy lifestyle you can imagine
and Matthew McConaughey's look how gaunt
he was how skinny he was how frail it
just sold it this is the best
performance I have ever seen from that
actor and not just because of his weight
loss he just did such a great job as
this guy I completely bought this
character and I fell for him you know it
really is realistic it really sells its
own time and space this movie is very
good and making you feel like you are
watching a real location real people
interacting in it it really understands
the time and space that it's in also
fantastic is Jared Leto and this
miletto Leto whatever I like his music I
like his performances in this movie that
is a performance right there because
again there were times in the movie
where I actually started to think of his
character as a woman and it was very
impressive that he pulled that off
because that is something that yeah you
can't really fool me with that and yes I
knew that it's Jared Leto but he just
was a woman in this movie he did such a
terrific job of his performance and the
movie isn't flawless
it has inconsistencies in tone there are
times when it jumps from sort of
light-hearted to very dark and it feels
very rushed sometimes where it goes to
those tonal shifts Jennifer Garner is in
the movie and I don't really have
anything against her but I didn't really
feel like she was on the same level as
the other actors in the film either the
movie has a very handheld style I think
it may have benefited from a more steady
hand behind the camera nevertheless
Dallas buyers club is a film that really
got in me you know it really got under
my skin and after the movie I was
driving home I had like a 40-minute
drive home from this theater and I was
just feeling it I mean like I was
feeling it like it just was on my mind
and the weight of it was on my shoulders
and that's something you can always say
about good movies is when you leave the
theater and you feel like discussing it
with others the various things it has to
say about the Food and Drug
Administration and hospitals and how
they don't really quite give patients
always what they need because there are
certain things there only approved to
give and this movie really delves deep
into that and there are times when it
feels a little cliched and certain
characters feel like they're just sort
of like this facade where they're not
really a person they're just supposed to
be the evil Hospital doctor guy but the
performances are so good that some of
these things are overlooked because the
weight of these actors portrayal of
these characters is so strong I'm gonna
give Dallas buyers club a B+ I think
it's a very good movie it could have
benefitted from a little bit more of a
steady direction there are some tonal
inconsistencies but dear Lord the acting
is just out of this world Matthew
McConaughey has seriously turned his
career around I mean every scene he was
in with Jennifer Garner I was like they
were in ghosts of Girlfriends Past
he really has turned his career in a
completely opposite direction so guys
have you seen the movie what do you
think of the performances do you think
they're award-worthy I do
let me know below and as always guys
thanks very much for watching and if you
liked this you can click right here and
get stuck mine eyes
[Music]